alicia the taliban declaring victory
over every province in afghanistan after
two weeks of fierce fighting in the
panshir province still resistance
fighters say they're still holding on to
strategic positions let's bring in fox
news contributor joey jones earned a
purple heart for his service in
afghanistan where he lost both legs and
an explosion that also severely damaged
his right arm in both wrists he's also
host of the new fox nation streaming
special the longest war available right
now joey you and i talk often about
matters like this and you have been very
outspoken and thank you first for your
service i'll say it every time we bring
you on the air but i want to get your
reaction we're just hearing now
about
whether or not we might have to go back
you may have heard some of our jennifer
griffin was interviewing uh general
milley the chairman of joint chiefs
saying you know it's really too
soon to tell whether or not there will
be a reconstitution of al qaeda whether
we might have to go back well now we
have senator lindsey graham talking to
the bbc weighing in i want you to listen
to what he's just said and get your
reaction watch
sorry about that i'm going to read you a
quote if i can just drop that in the
prompter
which we don't have just yet but listen
he's essentially saying ariel finally
sorry we will be going back into
afghanistan as we went back into iraq in
syria he says we'll have to we'll have
to because the threat will be so large
it could be a cauldron for radical
islamic behavior your thoughts
yeah you know if you read the room i
mean just look at that miley interview
with jennifer griffin
there's no confidence whatsoever that
we're safer or that we won't have to do
this that doesn't mean definitively we
will have to fight them again
but i've spoken to retired four star
generals i've spoken to active two and
three star generals and you know
everyone from the most moderate who said
afghanistan was a nice to have not a
need to have to you know a retired
four-star is pretty well known all all
feel like the threat is still there like
it was before we got there and and
hopefully they're starting to take some
accountability and understand their own
role in that but i think politicians
don't help at all i mean lindsey graham
was you know on tv advocating for us to
back this coalition force that's in
northern afghanistan in the ponzi valley
and i guess now they've been defeated so
i don't know that he understood really
what he was trying to get us to do at
least lindsey graham has been honest i
mean he said all along forever that he
wants to keep troops there at least
that's honest i don't think other
politicians have been quite as blatant
about it
but i don't think our government has
done a good job explaining to the
american people or at least selling us
on that national security threat and
part of that is because as long as they
could fund the war every two years
they really haven't felt the need to and
i think it's our turn as the american
people
to ask bigger questions and to get
bigger answers so we understand what the
threats are and why we would need to go
there before we go again right well let
me ask you this joey are we safer uh
after this withdrawal
is there is there just as much of a
threat if not a more empowered threat
absolutely i mean you can't look at 20
years of war and not think we've
probably made more enemies there they
they really emboldened the taliban by
going and recruiting young men that get
romanticized on the idea of jihad and a
lot of them most of them probably come
from pakistan and the madrasa is there
so so the idea of radical islam is
probably stronger now than it's ever
been the one thing that's different is
our own defenses here at home the way
we're looking at threats the way we
survey things and the way we look at who
comes into our country or supposed to
look at who comes into our country i can
tell you just as someone with a top
secret clearance read in on things that
have already happened to learn from we
we deter threats
i mean every single day
we do indeed joy jones thank you for
coming on on this labor day and thank
you for your service sir
thank you